[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute netz
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann ein
sogenannter von mir und da sind einige
unserer themen heute
unheilbar demonstration in berlin für
soziale gerechtigkeit zehntausende durch
die hauptstadt
proteste und kämpfe in afghanistan die
taliban verschieben erneut die
regierungsbildung und
vier medaillen und ein deutscher
weltrekord in tokio bei strömendem regen
läuft linde über 400 meter fabelzeit
[Musik]
welches thema ist sehr wichtig für ihre
wahlentscheidung das war eine frage im
aktuellen zdf politbarometer
die meisten befragten 52 prozent sagten
soziale gerechtigkeit das thema treibt
um in der hauptstadt gingen die menschen
heute dafür auf die straße für gerechte
löhne und wirkliche teilhabe von allen
dazu gleich mehr zunächst thomas konsum
mit einigen fakten
einkommen vermögen bildung drei
gradmesser dafür ob es gerecht zugeht in
deutschland die löhne die inflation
mitgerechnet sie steigen seit 2007 im
schnitt bei allen einkommensgruppen
allerdings verdienen vor allem menschen
in leitenden positionen mehr 40 prozent
weniger profitieren fachkräfte und
geringqualifizierte während der pandemie
schwächte sich die ungleichheit bisher
etwas ab aber nur weil
einkommensstärkeren noch größere
finanzielle einbußen hatten als alle
anderen sehr klare unterschiede zeigen
sich bei den vermögen in deutschland
besitzt das reichste zehntel mehr als 67
prozent des gesamten vermögens also zwei
drittel tendenz noch steigend immerhin
nimmt auch die chance auf höhere bildung
zu seit 2008 gibt es immer mehr menschen
mit abitur und mit hochschulabschluss
sie haben bessere möglichkeiten auf dem
arbeitsmarkt und wiederum die chance auf
höheres einkommen und vermögen
wir wollen eine umverteilung von oben
nach unten diesem aufruf sind drei
wochen vor der bundestagswahl in berlin
trotz corona tausende von menschen
gefolgt
organisator ist das bündnis unteilbar
dazu gehören über 300 organisationen
unter anderem das deutsche
kinderhilfswerk amnesty international
pro asyl die tafeln und fridays for
future beatz schneider berichtet
solidarisch miteinander leben auch auf
den anderen achten das motto klingt sehr
schön und sehr allgemein fragt man die
demonstranten konkret was für sie eine
gerechte gesellschaft bedeutet kommt
immer wieder das thema löhne
bereich im gesundheitswesen arbeitet
muss sich da ganz besonders was ändern
denn es kann nicht sein dass
krankenhäuser an die freie wirtschaft
angelehnt sind und wie
wirtschaftsunternehmen arbeiten müssen
ich denke aber auch das ganze personal
in kitas
erzieherinnen erzieher zum beispiel sind
auch eine ganz wichtige gruppe die mehr
einfach mehr geld für ihre arbeit
kriegen sollten das krasser armut
bekämpft wird sowohl hier in deutschland
aber auch weltweit
das alles so wenig das existenzminimum
haben aber es gibt noch mehr was die
menschen bewegt dass alle menschen
wohnraum haben den sie sich leisten
können und der ihrer würdig ist der
klimaschutz ja wir haben nur eine erde
und die seite bewohnbar bleiben
möglicherweise ist die pandemie die
angst vor ansteckung schuld dass nicht
so viele gekommen sind wie erhofft die
polizei spricht von 10.000 demonstranten
der veranstalter von 30.000 vor der
bundestagswahl will das aktionsbündnis
die politik aufrütteln
wir zeigen dass wir uns alle miteinander
verbunden sind dass die
zivilgesellschaft ganz klare forderungen
und visionen hat für eine lebenswerte
zukunft für alle menschen die hier leben
die gesellschaft der vielen das corona
sicherheitskonzept hat nach angaben der
polizei gut funktioniert die gruppen
marschierten weit auseinandergezogen mit
maske
nach afghanistan die vereinten nationen
warnen wenn nicht mehr geld fließt droht
dem land ein humanitäres desaster eine
geberkonferenz am 13 september in gelben
soll nun abhilfe schaffen in kabul zieht
sich die regierungsbildung unter den
taliban weiterhin grund sind auch
unruhen im land jörg brase berichtet
taliban ihr verletzt die rechte der
frauen rufen sie auch heute
demonstrierten frauenorganisationen in
der afghanischen hauptstadt
ich will den frauen helfen die bisher
nicht wieder zur arbeit nicht zur schule
gehen durften ich will ihre stimme sein
der protest wurde von spezialkräften
aufgelöst es soll verletzte gegeben
haben auf die mauern in der hauptstadt
lassen die neuen machthaber parolen
schreiben wir gratulieren euch zu eurer
freiheit die bilanz leute lautet eine
die gesichter des alten regimes werden
übermalt die namen die bilder der neuen
regierung aber fehlen noch von der
rückkehr zur normalität wagt ihr noch
niemand zu sprechen
viele sind verunsichert weil es keine
arbeit gibt und weil immer noch keine
regierung ernannt wurde das stört sehr
viele menschen denn wir wissen nicht wie
die zukunft unseres landes aussehen
grund für die erneute verschiebung der
regierungsbildung sind vermutlich die
kämpfe im pandschir tal dort haben sich
verschiedene oppositionsgruppen zu einer
nationalen widerstandsfront gegen die
taliban zusammengetan darunter auch der
vizepräsident der von den taliban
vertriebenen zentralregierung
wir werden unser land verteidigen der
widerstand geht weiter wir haben viele
taliban getötet sie töteten viele
unserer soldaten wir haben sie gestern
begraben auch heute werden wir wieder
von 23 seiten angegriffen aber wir haben
die situation unter kontrolle
während nicht weit von der hauptstadt
weiter gekämpft wird wurde der zivile
flugverkehr auf dem flughafen wieder
aufgenommen
mit hilfe aus dem nachbarland pakistan
wurde das rollfeld repariert am samstag
starteten die ersten inlandsflüge nach
der machtübernahme der taliban sind auch
mindestens fünf hochrangige politiker
aus afghanistan nach deutschland
geflüchtet das meldet der spiegel unter
den mehr als 4.500 ausgeflogen sind nach
angaben von innenminister seehofer 20
flüchtlinge die den sicherheitsbehörden
bekannt sind unter ihnen sind auch
verurteilte straftäter und
terrorverdächtige
jetzt zu corona unter steigen auch heute
die zahl der neuinfektionen weiter an
das robert koch institut meldet zehn
1835 neue corona fälle innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 532 mehr als am
vergangenen samstag 24 todesfälle kamen
binnen eines tages hinzu die sieben tage
incidents liegt bei 80,7
scharfe kritik am bahnsteig von
ungewohnter seite der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund bemängelt dass die
gewerkschaft deutscher lokführer
einzelinteressen über das
gesamtinteresse alle anderen bahn
beschäftigen stelle so dgb chef hoffmann
in der rheinischen post man dürfe die
beschäftigtengruppen eines unternehmens
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen
am wochenende will die bahn 30 prozent
der züge im fernverkehr anbieten zuletzt
waren es 25 prozent im nahverkehr sind
rund 40 prozent der züge unterwegs die
lokführergewerkschaft will noch bis
dienstag strecken
in drei wochen wird nicht nur ein neuer
bundestag gewählt sondern in mecklenburg
vorpommern auch ein neuer landtag im
moment regiert spd ministerpräsidentin
schwesig mit einer großen koalition eine
der wichtigsten branchen in dem
küstenland ist der tourismus gebeutelt
von corona und verzweifelt auf der suche
nach fachkräften
bernd mosebach hat mehr die hotels auf
usedom sind gut gebucht eigentlich
könnte jetzt richtig geld verdient
werden im tourismus doch hoteliers wie
christa wenig gefehlt personal seit
jahren schon die korona zwangspause hat
die lage noch einmal verschärft da sind
keine fachkräfte da sind keine
arbeitskräfte da wir haben abwanderungen
von 25 bis 30 prozent innerhalb unserer
branche viele mitarbeiter sind jetzt zu
einem bewusstsein gekommen dass sie
gesagt haben unsere branche ist nicht
mehr krisenfest sondern wir müssen uns
anders orientieren seine terrasse kann
er wegen personalmangels erst am
nachmittag öffnet vor drei jahren ist er
nach vietnam geflogen hat auszubildende
angeworben tantra ist eine davon von 20
ausbildungsplätzen sind 15 besetzte 12
mit vietnamesen untergebracht in
personalwohnungen er hat sich das
gelohnt für
[Musik]
die erwerbsfähige bevölkerung schrumpft
besonders im osten ohne einwanderung
waren experten drohen schwierige zeiten
nicht nur für die tourismusbranche in
deutschland ist auch nicht unbedingt das
attraktivste land auf der welt für
internationale fachkräfte und da müssen
wir noch eine schippe drauflegen und vor
allen dingen auch eine willkommenskultur
die im ausland sich etablieren gerade im
osten fast alle größeren parteien in
mecklenburg vorpommern bis auf die fdp
setzen auf mehr einwanderung von fach
und arbeitskräften auch jörg butt sucht
bisher vergeblich mitarbeiter da muss
man keine große ausbildung zu haben also
eigentlich kann jeder könnte jeder der
keinen job bei uns arbeiten und muss
seinen laden einen tag in der woche
schließen und so gibt es mitten in der
hauptsaison immer dienstags keine
fischbrötchen in zinnowitz auf usedom
der deutsche aktienindex bekommt neue
mitglieder zehn unternehmen sind aus dem
nebenwerte-index mdax aufgerückt
darunter der flugzeugbauer airbus die
porsche holding und der online
modehändlers zalando ziel der
erweiterung auf jetzt 40 unternehmen ist
die deutsche wirtschaft besser
abzubilden wer im dax bleiben will muss
künftig zudem noch strengere regeln
erfüllen
in den usa hat präsident joe biden den
leidtragenden des hurricans einer
unterstützung zugesagt bei einem besuch
im katastrophengebiet im süden des
landes sagte biden bei dem wiederaufbau
dürften politische motive keine rolle
spielen im bundesstaat louisiana und dem
benachbarten mississippi waren infolge
des hurricans mindestens 13 menschen ums
leben gekommen claudia bates berichtet
dieser baum längst hatte er gewollt dass
er gefällt wird im sturm wurde dennis
duplessis in seinem auto darunter
begraben
wenn ich meine augen schließe sehe ich
wie der baum auf ihn stürzt es ist
einfach schrecklich der baum der
erfasste
es sind solche geschichten des leids die
joe biden sich anhört er versucht trost
zu spenden versucht nähe zu zeigen und
sagt umfassende hilfe zu essen wasser
generatoren und unterstützung beim
wiederaufbau
naja ich weiß dass sie leiden das weiß
ich ich möchte dass sie wissen wir
werden für sie da sein
viele gegenden sind noch überschwemmt
häuser sind komplett zerstört und
weiterhin hat fast eine million menschen
keinen strom
alte holzmasten die marode infrastruktur
müsse besser als vorher aufgebaut werden
meint beiden ansonsten würde sie dem
klimawandel nicht standhalten
die dinge haben sich in sachen umwelt so
drastisch verändert wir haben bestimmte
schwellen überschritten man kann eine
straße eine brücke nicht wieder so
aufbauen wie sie vorher waren
beiden nutzte die gelegenheit für seinen
infrastrukturpaket zu werben dass fast
eine billion dollar für straßen brücken
stromnetze vorsieht ein dankeschön noch
für die vielen helfer nun müssen in
washington mehrheiten für die
versprechungen gesichert werden
wir schauen nach südamerika venezuela
rutscht immer weiter ins chaos
die wirtschaft liegt am boden das geld
ist praktisch wertlos die kriminalität
ist enorm angestiegen die vereinten
nationen schätzen dass mittlerweile 5,6
millionen venezolaner auf der flucht
sind viele bleiben erstmal im
nachbarland kolumbien
das selbst unter armut und corona leidet
christoph rath berichtet aus der
grenzstadt kuta
die verzweiflung ist größer als die
entfernung johanna böhl nach peru 3000
kilometer sind das erzählt sie uns sie
ist schwanger ihr kind soll an einem
besseren ort auf die welt kommen für
mein kind ist der bauch das sicherste
transportmittel
johanna kommt dass venezuela
sie ist eine von mehr als zwei millionen
flüchtlingen die zurzeit in kolumbien
unterwegs sind viele stranden gleich
hier hinter der grenze in cúcuta sowie
emily und ihre fünf kinder vor mehr als
zwei jahren sind sie aus ihrer heimat
geflohen und doch nie wirklich
angekommen in kolumbien kein geld kein
dach keine ahnung wohin
die leute haben zu mir gesagt ich solle
mich prostituieren so viele üble dinge
sogar drogen zu verkaufen haben sie mir
vorgeschlagen aber dafür bin ich nicht
hergekommen ich bin hergekommen um
meinen kindern ein besseres leben zu
ermöglichen
emily ist studierte grundschullehrerin
doch das gehalt in venezuela reichte
nicht einmal fürs essen und so entschied
sie sich zur flucht es folgten monate
voller not und gefahr bis das rote kreuz
die aufnahme doch auf dauer hier bleiben
können sie nicht
wir haben diese unterkunft erst vor drei
tagen eröffnet und in diesen drei tagen
schon 40 personen aus zehn familien
aufgenommen das zeigt dass der bedarf
hier sehr groß ist
denn noch immer kommen sie zu tausenden
über die grenze die krise venezuela es
dauert an selbst wenn sie etwas aus dem
blickfeld der welt geraten zu sein
scheint
jetzt zu den paralympics norbert wieder
mit beeindruckenden deutschland frei wir
allerdings beginnen wir mit der
leichtathletik da hat sprinter felix
strenge über 200 meter seine zweite
goldmedaille knapp verpasst dagegen
sorgte linde für eine faustdicke
überraschung über 400 meter gold und
weltrekord in exakt einer minute
völlig durchnässt im japanischen
dauerregen gelingt in die aare ein
goldenes rennen die durch eine
zerebralparese behinderte greifswalderin
ist über die 400 meter die schnellste
nach bronze über 100 nun also gold über
die 400 meter eine sicherlich sonnige
erinnerung an tokio wenig streng ist
nach seinem sieg über die 100 meter nun
auch im finale über 200 meter der
favorit nach der hälfte des rennens noch
gleichauf nimmt ihnen der costa ricaner
sammeln die tg aber bis ins ziel rund
zwei meter ab der einseitig
unterschenkelamputierte streng hat in
tokio damit sein zweites gold verpasst
aber silber gewonnen und
auch im kanusport gab es zwei medaillen
felicia langer holte bei ihrem
paralympics debüt bronze und ex
basketballerin ina müller sogar gold
letztendlich haben sich alle
anstrengungen gelohnt neun jahre nach
ihrem paralympics sieg im
rollstuhl-basketball gewinnt diener
müller wieder gold diesmal im kanu
sprint der querschnittgelähmten
vergessen die kräftezehrenden umstände
die sie als stillende mutter eines
zweijährigen sohnes gemeistert hat
[Applaus]
ist es wirklich unbeschreiblich wenn man
da wirklich durch ist nach all dem im
schweiß und tränen wie immer also das ja
durch halt wenn man wenn man dadurch
erste als erste durchs ziel fährt ist es
wirklich der wahnsinn auch die
20-jährige felicia la barra erfolgreich
die durch eine bei missbildung
gehandicapte debütantin fährt als
dritter über die ziellinie und gewinnt
bronze
große enttäuschung dagegen bei den
deutschen rollstuhl basketballerin im
spiel um bronze verloren sie gegen die
usa mit 51 zu 64 zu den us open hat
angelique kerber das achtelfinale
erreicht deutschlands beste
tennisspielerin setzte sich mit 5 7 6 2
und 6 3 gegen die us amerikanerin sloane
stephens durch und zeigte dabei eine
überzeugende leistung kerber trifft nun
auf die erst 18 jahre alte kanadierin
leila fernandes
das wars vom sport geschändete schön das
wetter bleibt herrlich spätsommerlich
wie warm es noch wird erzählt gleich aus
dem verlies das heute journal um viertel
vor elf und marietta slomka wir wünschen
ihnen einen unbeschwerten samstagabend
bis morgen wenn sie morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das warme spätsommerwetter setzt
sich weiter fort möglich macht es dieses
hoch hier bei den britischen inseln
stehen sehe ich weiter aus bringt
allerdings in den norden durchaus
feuchte luft das bedeutet dort gibt es
mehr wolken und das auch in der
kommenden nacht bereits enorm also
dichter bewölkt in gewässernähe bildet
sich nebel nach süden hin ist es
aufgeklart hier funkeln über nacht die
sterne und die temperaturen sinken vor
allem im süden auf 7 grad am kühlsten
häufiger werte unter der zehn grad marke
im südwesten sind 13 und auch an der
nordsee das sind die milden temperaturen
da kommt nachts morgen im tagesverlauf
dann nach nebelauflösung auch im norden
etwas sonnenschein aber die wolken
überwiegend im gegensatz zum süden da
ist häufig sonnenschein dabei im
südwesten kann es zum nachmittag dann
einige schauer geben die höchsten
temperaturen dazu bis 28 grad im
südwesten deutlich kühler mit 19 grad
richtung ostsee und warm geht es weiter
in den nächsten tagen montag bis 28
dienstag ähnlich warm und 29 grad am
mittwoch ein schöner abend